Alexis Rozanski: Good luck!
Daniel Friedman: Hello. >>> Avel Guénin-Carlut: I'm ready.
Yes, we are in. It is January 23,
2023. We're here in Active
Inference Gueststream number 34.1
with Avel Guénin-Carlut. We're going to
have a 1 hour presentation, "Physics of
Creation: Can the free energy principle
ground the construction of physical
statespaces?" followed by about an hour
discussion. So if you're watching live,
please feel free to add questions in the
live chat and we'll also have some
guests. So thank you Avel for joining! And
off to you for the presentation.
Avel: Hello. So this is a complete
presentation. I will first introduce
myself and the work I am I have
employment physics. I'm working creative
science under version of And Clark.
This work is instantly speaking the
product of Kyros research which is
laboratory which myself, Alex Rozanski,
who is present here today and other
people are funded to investigate issues
of relevance to political political
evolution and community science.
And the the topic will be on the physics
of creation. So creation is an Attial
term, let us say it will be
contextualized in the presentation. But
let us first define that it corresponds
to the construction of physical
possibilities, physical test basis to
talk in a more technical language. And
the original question that motivated
this research is whether or not the
federal principle a piece of math that's
emergence cognitive evidence which we
will get to very sooner is
capable of representing this process of
creation. So first,
I have tried the first run of this
without getting into the technicals, it
did not work. So I will address the
technicals. First we will see some
concepts in physics, what they do, how
they work, how they relate to what
people typically do in physics. And
first I'd like to take a look at how
physics explain. So, physics explain
with laws. They think that in
nature you have laws and those laws are
basically formal statements that
constrain the possible states of a
system. And typically those are
entailing laws that from which you can
derive logically what the system will
do. An example of natural entertaining
law is Maxwell's equation of
electromagnetics. It is a different
Maxwell than the one that is here.
So what you see is four bits of
vectorial calculus that will tell you
how two Fields that
are collectively the electromagnetic
field evolve with regard
to another. So this is a formal
constraint on what ENB can do, like the
quality express constraint by
definition. And those can be used to
derive basically fully E and B given
boundary conditions, which is how you do
things in electromagnetism.
But what is of relevance here is that
any of the slope presposes basically
that I can define E as a virtual field.
So it presupposes what is called set
space, which is mathematical space that
represents a set of possible states.
Before I state delta E and delta B is
equal to this and this I have to state
that E exists and e can
take such and such states. In that case,
it is a vectoral space in three
dimensions and this
space basically it does by construction
to capture any difference that make a
difference about the system that is
targeted for any change in e.
To be basically computable by my theory,
it has to be represented in the set
space. So by construction I ant the
space to categorify every variable
of interests in my system. Given the
scope and measurement capabilities of
my theory,
you have underlying notion that
is basically implicitly underlying
the notion of flows and space, that is
the notion of symmetry. I cannot get
into the Brea detail here, but I will
try to be as complete as possible.
We typically understand physical
theories outside specifically relativity
theory and some weird quantum stuff to
Deneve from symmetries. Symmetries are,
I will say it out loud algebraic Ronen
of transformation of other space that do
not affect the system's dynamics as
blunted as it's laplacene. You don't
have to understand what I just said.
What you have to understand is that
there are ways in which I can transform
the system which does not change what it
is. An example in symmetries the sailing
of the Jorge force arm of skin is field
you see that you have physically the
same pattern that is repeated again and
again and again readily. So if I make
a small rotation in either direction,
it will not change a thing and if I
repeat it and repeat it and repeat it
and repeat it and repeat it and repeat
it, I will still change my system. Like
formally I will apply consummation but
it does not change basically what
observable properties the system have.
And this is what a symmetry is.
It is a set of transformation that is
generated by a subset of smaller
transformation and that does not change
what the system observably is. And
because of this asymmetry of a system
that basically constrain what difference
can make a difference about the system.
So implication, when I formulate law
or state space I make a statement about
the underlying symmetries. I make the
statement that basically everything
that is not in the system that is not
represented as part of the system is
something that is symmetric, that the
system is symmetric with regard to that
on which any transformation will not
affect the system trajectory. At least
not in a way that is relevant to my
theory.
It works for physics because it looks
like in physics we have few symmetries
that are everywhere verified that are
fundamental in some sense it doesn't
work so well in life and mind because we
don't have that. To be specific, living
system have a structure, I do not think
it should be controversial and they have
considered asymmetry they have changes
that will not affect them. If I switch
all of the carbon atoms by body, I
scramble them between each other while
keeping the relation to rest. It did not
change a thing. So it is very trivial in
sense of symmetry. But basically every
structure that is me entails
symmetries entails information that are
possible that do not affect the
structure and other tools affect it.
And the structure it is not a given
like symmetries are considered to be in
physics. It is active reconstructed by
the activity of me. If I cut myself, if
I fall, if my bone break, I will regrow.
Basically, we'll have circumficial
tissue that will occur and that will
make it okay again and it will change
what software is my body.
Most importantly, I was
not born that way. Like big and with a
bird and with 80 kilo of meat. I grew
and I grew from one single cell. And
this single cell just created an atomia
structure apparently ex nelo from
basically a genetic code in the context.
And not only that, but life in and of
itself evolves in a way that builds
structures that build asymmetry. And all
of this means that you can't set a stack
space that is the set space of life in
general of any living system. The
symmetries that in the life system they
change to time and they change by the
own activity of this system. So any
living system construct set spaces and
to account for it we need a theory of
set space construction. This is the
motivation of the physics of creation
line of work. And this is basically I
did not permit as a question. It is the
question that we need to keep in mind in
this discussion. So Daniel, do we have
any question yet?
Anyone? Okay, no technical issue that I
should know about?
Okay, so what we'll do is first look at
basically what we say of creation in
life in mind, at a conceptual level,
what is the history of the concept and
what I ant to do then we'll look into
the formal specifics of how we
try to represent physical recognition as
coherence and what limits these attempts
have. And finally,
we will take the reflection further and
see whether we can and how far we can
represent physical creation. The
construction of physical reality with
the tentative formalism we have framed
here. So let us
look at creation in life in mind.
Historically, the term of creation, it
refers to autopoieces. That means
literally self creation. And that is
attempt by an activist what became an
activist so mainly matureana
and varietal to ground the study of
cognition, the study of biology and the
way, well, the living system work.
They framed Autophagic theory as
basically the idea that cognition is
grounded in a way that link system
constructs itself, like their
metabolism, allow them to reconstruct
the structure. And the structure does
not have to be conserved by metabolism.
So you have self creation. And this is
basically the concept that try to
articulate to ground cognitive science
and later Variety and colleagues
tried to basically concretize this by
working on how the cognition was
enacted, which is it is implemented in
the body and in the concrete. Activity
of living systems. And this basically
was very determined to the cognitive
evidence and it framed the four E
approach. So the attention of cognition
beyond the brain let us say very
tentatively, the idea
that they frame is that you
can see the diagram that is taken from
the Paulo's work. And I tried to explain
the correlation between self
constitution. So let us say it is a
weaker, lighter, more specified notion
of the paraesis and agency. The idea is
that you have self constitution. That is
the fact that the system build
themselves and it is basically afforded
by the way during system couple with
environments. An agency is later higher
order of regulation of this. Disability
to define basically the terms of field
coupling with the environment.
And the idea generates
is that living systems there are systems
that have structural identity
that they actively generate and sustain
under precarious circumstances. There is
no benevolent universe that helps life,
that help life be life. Life has
basically to generate environment where
it is life and in doing so, it generates
and it sustains what it is,
its identity. And all of this is
necessary for sense making so let us say
cognition to be something to occur and
this is, in my opinion and to
some extent in dePolo's own opinion
somewhat wordy it is a lot of concepts,
a lot of Greek words and people have
tried to frame this in a way that is
more mathematical and formal. And the
question it generates is how to
formalize this selfcreative property of
biological colonialization and cognition
and in a way that is basically grounded
in material informational flow, in
things that are concrete physical
structure. We have a
pretty good answer to that, actually.
We have pretty good work that made a
point that you had related this
somewhat high level concept to basic
physical processes. This work is the
work of Moreno Monsieur and Monteville
mainly, who work in forgot the name but
institute of and study in the Paybasque
in Spain. And the idea is that living
systems axel Costa by a closure of
constraints. So the constraint is
physical thing that shape how other
physical thing work? Very simple. If I
have air in a box that is closed, the
air can't live a box. It is a
constraint. Okay. And the property that
integrates living things is the fact
that they are constituted
by a set of constraints that can lie
metabolism in a way that reconstructs
the same way, the same system of
constraints. And so
from there you have selfconstitution.
You have also structural, let us say,
notion of biology that does not depend
on the matter it is made of, but on the
way it is sustained. That is, I think,
pretty good if you ant to have a
physicalist notion of life.
And we have
a very basic ontology in which
constraints may shape metabolism and
shape information flow as in the way
Livingston react to things and that
grounds the autonomy of living things,
the fact that they can recreate
themselves basically. But nothing gives
a clear link between this and cognitive
meaning or anything we could recognize
as cognition. So this is what we will
try to articulate next. So how driving
systems as we just defined can create
meaning. The notion I would like to
import is the notion of active in France
which I will not get into the
mathematical detail here. But the idea
is that the way the dynamics flow
literally that is entailed by an agent
and its environment it individuals
states that are meaningful basically an
agent will predict in a relatively
formal sense sensations that it
will not perceive perceive
but undergo and actions that we'll
undertake. And these predictions are
basically what's underlying meaningful
the agent it underlies what states will
just so happen to shape its own action
and be meaningful to them. This can
be framed by in a pretty simple
poetic move by saying that biological
generative systems they do not simply
infer what is they bring about their
own reality by actively inferring what
is meaningful to them, by actively
looking for states that they think are
really don't fault their own structure.
And then you start to have a stronger
relation between what a physical system
of constraint is and how it individuates
states that are meaningful. But you
still don't have a formal theory of
basically how this metabolic flow builds
learning or creation like builds
a new state of possible, a new space
sorry of possible states that is not the
one it began with.
I have a description of a structure that
is the set of constraints and this
produces basically an activity of the
system, a flow of a destructure. And
this flow, it somehow constrains or
shape the structure. The system takes a
time t plus one which itself produce new
function, a new flow, et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera. So it is this dynamic
of I don't know what to call that self
differentiate, unfolding, whatever the
way a system of constraint
produce a flow that triple the system of
constraint that we want to formalize.
And the question we could
reframe as such we could reframe as how
does cognition, the ability to
understand, integrates information about
the world it enacts within biological
organization? Because cognition is
basically the flow of biological
organization. At least you can tell by
it. Everything that I see is something
that I ant to say, bring about, that I
look at because of the biological
constraints I am. And therefore
the question of creation can be reframed
as how the meaning of projections to the
world is brought back to shape my own
structure. And this is
what we will try to frame mathematically
in the framework active Inference Lab
Daniel, any questions.
So the attempt
that we make here is to see if we can
how basically we can represent creation
as a process of inference, which is
likely the most minimal, highly
recognizable way I could frame cognition
as something that is distinct from
simply.
Let us look at a piece of math that is
called the Fancy principle and that is
the formal motivation or grounding for
active in France. It will
be the hard part for people who do not
do math or people who are not already
familiar with principle I will work with
slowly it is a piece of math that frames
statistical coherence from the
mechanical system theory. Chemical
system theory is basically the idea that
you have states and they move as a
function of each other. And what the FEP
does is to prove that. If I have
something that is called Markov blanket
so boundary that
any information must travel through for
two subsystem to communicate radically
then you have a synchronization that
emerged between states that are outside
this boundary and states that are inside
this boundary. And not
only this, but if I measure basically
every state that is on the inside of the
boundary entails belief, entails equal
distribution over the external states
and the flow of internal states is such
that it minimizes the international
distance between the
actual external states. Well,
what I can observe and what I believe to
be the case where I of course is the
external states so that was abstract.
The basic and formal meaning of this
is that if I have a chemical system and
I have a boundary that acts to mediate
information exchange between two
subparts then both subparts can
basically represent each other and hold
belief in each other in a way that
is constructed by the systematic
synchronization across the boundary. It
is quite abstract and quite minimal.
But it is a foul proof that we can have
representation, we can have cognitive
meaning from a very very minimal set
of hypothesis, which is basically a
consistent causal structure. And it is a
pretty good case that basic technical
system, for example constraints,
constraint will be motoring robots this
kind of very basic noncommittee things
can entail cognitive niche
has been argued that it does underly
agency and creativity and similar
concepts that would entail, in my
opinion, creation as a prerequisite. So
we'll try to see whether the FEP
actually can represent creation as the
ability for agent to individuate states
that are spinning to them.
The thing is that the existence of Mark
of Blancate is monitoring for any
complex stochastic chemical system so
chemical system that are random and this
transmission realized as basically
something that moves in function of
itself plus random noise it is
a very generative formulation arguably
anything that exists can be framed
as such. So we should be optimistic
for the ability of this to
represent the cognitive introduction
of cognitive meaning by basic biological
system and therefore creation it is not
the case because when I frame something
as x of te equal something when
I have to preface x we have to define
space of states that is x.
And I have defined creation as the
ability to construct basically physical
possibilities. So by construction
if you frame something within the
Microsoft theory you have to interview
states a priority. What you have written
down is not creation. It can be a ant of
creation. It can be interesting in the
study of creation. It is not creation,
it is not the construction of physical
spaces and it is likely not the
construction of cognitive meaning at
least in the sense that an activist and
autopoietic theory people mean it.
It just underwrites what become
measurable for a given subsystem within
the stochastic chemical system which is
a lot but is not again creation.
Let us think about how we
should go. We should think of creation.
There will be more math here, I'm
afraid. But if a system is
to observe another system it
will have to lose information about its
broader environment. It is pretty
easy. It is something can derive from
first principle because basically
if you frame it as a quantum system
observation will entail entanglement by
definition I observe a system and it
becomes something that has in the states
because I become entangled with it.
So its states become physically
synchronized with my state. But I cannot
synchronize with everything all the
time. So if I act so
as to have more knowledge about the
object, I act so as to have
less knowledge about my environment. So
there is no basically Costa less
observation. It is something that can be
derived in the quantum setting that can
be reframed in other way in classical
settings. Because of the way observation
will either induce heating information
loss or cause myself to
forget information. You can pretty much
derive it in a variety of case. It is
likely true in all cases. And it means
that observation as
it is constrained by my own flow and the
way I culture with the environment it
does not simply entail the observation
of preexisting well integrated physical
states. It brings about well
defined observables for me to observe
the way how to say given
this it is hard maybe not possible to
frame a theory of conversation from a
mathematical theory that entails a very
well and ejected physical states. If I
frame such a theory of observation or
measurement of cognitive meaning it will
not be general. And I
pretty much have to work creation on the
very fundamental scales ant which my
theory operates. And this is something
that is arguably done by reframing
of the engineer principle for generic
quantum systems by mainly crease Fields.
The idea is to use category
theoretic equivalence between lots
of things. I will definitely not get
into that. To will frame the
synchronization dynamic that's in view
that builds cognitive meaning.
According to the French principle as a
series of binary measurements are
equivalently asymmetry brain operators.
So the way a chemical system
synchronized with its environment under
the FEP is reframed here as
basically a series of binary questions
that I ask my environment and that
enforce my interaction with it in such a
way that the answers to my questions
become physical facts which
you can derive from water, general
quantum information theory background.
But that gives basically no structure
whatsoever to the measurement. Nothing
in this theory says what kind
of system can ask what kind of
questions. And this means that okay,
this drives correlation, maybe drives
individuation of physical possibilities,
physical observables. But it does not
constrain at all what this creation is.
So it does not explain much and doesn't
help much to understand how living
system recreates itself. So we still
have somehow to recruit the cognitive
and immigrant formulation of the FEP
that I discussed very tentatively
earlier.
So let us take things from there.
I have turned during this formal
discussion from the notion that we have
to represent creation in the living and
cognitive world to the notion that
somehow it is necessary present creation
of physical reality like the underlying
states of physics.
This third part with this third part
will serve mainly to discuss this claim
and what it means and what
we should do with it. Basically.
First, I want to show basically
that the claim that there is no a
priority physical validity is a pretty
basic claim. It should not be treated as
exceptional. It is necessary property of
a coherent physics. It is necessary
property actually of the formulation or
description of a world that is beyond
what we call metaphysics. Let us be more
specific in the argumentation. I call
this argument that agent from
ontological consistency an ontology that
is naturalistic, that serves to present
nature, if it is consistent, cannot call
on to external objects that will not be
natural to explain the properties of its
own objects. For example, if I tell you
this thing is black because it reflects
the light in such and such way and I can
also explain the properties of light,
it is self consistent. If I tell you
this thing is black because God will
need and I cannot explain you what God
is physically, it is not self
consistent. There is no property that is
framed by Alexey Rozanski who is present
here as the property of self function.
Consistency that is that dentology
should basically include itself. The
discourse we have on physics is unless
we have very radical position about the
correlation between human and the other
world, it is something that exists in
nature and that is something that we
need to account as an
element of nature. This entails two
things. One thing actually it entails
that scientific presentations, the
models and theory we have and the
property those models and theory have,
they must be accounted for as natural
entities in their own rights and they
must be, at least in principle,
explanators by the tools of physics
and science. And this entails in turn
that I cannot have such a thing as
a law asymmetry or a set space that
preexist physics. Any statement I make
about physics must itself be explained
by physical processes. I will elaborate
on what it means. The view of physicist
is typically that we are theories and
those theories are representation of the
world that just so happen to account for
fundamental structure of the world. For
example, we have the Maxwell law of
electromagnetics electromagnetism
and those laws are representations
of a force that exists and
that is generative by su
one I think by asymmetry in
the Hamiltonian, sorry,
asymmetry in the quantum property of
systems. But this symmetry
preexists basically any attempt to
represent any physical process. It is a
fundamental property. What I say is that
you cannot have fundamental property,
you cannot have something that predates
physics and that cannot
ultimately be explained. And if you
admit such a thing, your ontology is not
consistent because you have to admit
some things that are beyond that predate
nature to exploration things in nature
which is the opposite of
what selfconsistency is.
So if I want to frame a world where
you do not have explanation that Conor
on two things that are beyond physics,
you have to have lots of entries in
spaces that are constructed by physical
processes. And it is not a problematic
view to have at least epistemologically,
it is necessary. Let us
discuss what it means concretely.
We have cognitive systems, not
coincidence systems they perceive. And
this perception brings about cognitively
relevant states which the cognitive
agent experience as real. We have
physical observers. These physical
observers bring about what we call
ponter states that are wellinvigorated
states that are measurable. And those
states constitute physical reality at
least as any given observer can
experience it. What I say here is
that this is not epistemic
notions. The ponting states and the
cognitively relevant states that
perception, the cognitive
relevant state under perception by
agents. They are Riol and they are
invigorated as riol by their
observation. And if we frame it
properly, the Qfep at least
what we could do with the Qfep.
It represents how protomines, at least
particles, agents that have properties
that we classically understand as
mindful, they individual physical
observable, which means that they create
a spaces, which means that this is a
theory of creation, not simply a theory
of how access reality, but a theory of
how we get reality in the first place.
And to do
anything like grounding properly this
claim, it will take a lot more details
and I will try to work
by showing what such a
theory would do because obviously I do
not have such a theory that is framed
formally from start to finish as of now.
And if I did, I would not present it.
Now let us look at the way constraint
basically creates the relative
experience this is Lagrange
of how, as humans on the world,
the social world,
basically, we understand things like
constraints over what we do and
can do and what entails. I understand
that if I talk to you in proper English,
you will understand if I talk to you in
French Australia, you will not
understand. Understand that if I
address, it will be inappropriate. And
if I hold myself in a certain way. It
will lead you to believe me more or less
understand that if I start speaking very
loud, it will disturb people and they
will act for me to stop talking very
loud. I understand very basic facts
about how this world work and I
understand how this constrained the
action I can take and the consequences
of that action. What experience is
basically a sociocultural escape which
exists independently from me and that I
act within. And what
I claim is that this sociocultural
landscape evolves in a way that is
creative, that is basically abuse. New
norms exist that did not exist ten years
ago. And that is even more true for 1
million ago or before human were a
thing. And the way I can represent how
Agent tried to understand this social
landscape and possibly fail our
errors, norms and the landscape in such
way it is equivalent representation of
the landscape itself and the constraints
that constitute this landscape and the
way the flow of the landscape
reconfigures the landscape. So what I
did here is to basically frame
a theory of creative evolution. These of
sets of constraints well of a structural
landscape on the way
individual agents ant understand and
act. Within this landscape, I have
sensed in which Costa observation and
cognition about physical. Here a social
reality, but still physical in the sense
that it exists in the physical world.
How this landscape can be created by
something that is cognitive and this
basic ontology, if I am correct, here is
something we can mathematize I hope so.
And that we can frame as a basic theory
of the individual, of new physical
possibilities, creation ie.
Note to this graph
is given to in a brilliant and
what is of importance here is the
duality between two representation, two
perspective the perspective of agents
that basically enact social culture
constraints that they experience as a
physical fact as a reality they cannot
go beyond or escape or maybe affect
in brute force. That's a possibility,
but not escape. And the perspective of a
set of constraints that endlessly
unfolds in a way that is creative and
that is a formal intuition I plan to
build on. And I can say
something a bit more specific about how
it works by analogy to the boundary
principle and the autographic principle.
Basically creation operator,
in my opinion, I could argue for that.
I will not do this in detail. Right now
is something that goes for space
of it's not actually a space. Of
physical possibilities. It's a space of
potentialities. It does not have
possible states and impossible states.
It is just the statement that something
is possible. It's very close to what
Greeks called chaos. So you have such a
space of unintivitted
possibilities and from this space
unfolds a pair of an individual
observable which is called e for
environment and an agent that is capable
to observe this observable. And the
agent is also capable to maintain
boundary between itself and the
observable. Or basically it's observable
to stay existing as observable to be
observed.
And from this, I think that
some mathematical operator that has this
basic flow is capable to describe
the construction of physical spaces as
the unfolding strictly strictly no
metaphorically a physical structure as
basically the
emergence, the coconstruction, the
integration, as you will, of well
integrated observable states. An
observer that is capable to see the
state and Bijan in active states
maintaining whatever worked as and
integrated space of possibilities before
as well integrated boundary between
itself and the system. Let us think,
for example, of a piece of paper. I,
an agent, can basically write things on
it. And by writing things on it I create
new physical observable which is the
content of what I've written. And the
fact I write on it and I read it makes
the piece of paper not a piece of
paper but a boundary between myself and
a semiotic space where the writing
occurs. This is the basic dynamic
that must be framed for us to understand
cognitive meaning and that if we framed
in such way could work to describe
the construction of the spaces x nilo
because literally you do not need
physical possibilities to be a thing for
B to exist. It is the point of this
presentation. You don't need a space of
possibilities to preexist the
function of the agent and the
government. This is why it is relevant
and this is why it is hard to formulate.
And given an operator with this property
we can pretty much work it back at the
function of physics and see what
happens. So how about physics of
creation? Let us tie
the threads of this presentation. I will
formulate three take on messages.
First, we have something that is called
the FEP that is not framed, that is
mainly framed as barriers and mechanics
as informational enrichment
of demeacosystem theory but that can
also be framed as something in quantum
information theory. It says that agents
actively infer states of bidding through
their engagement with the environment in
a way that maintains their structure.
This gives us a formal background.
The quantum frame it of the sorry,
quantum framing of it gives us very,
very generative and hard to say.
I would not say ill specified, but very
few specified doesn't have
a lot of detail. So it gives us a very
not detailed round for a study of how
committee meaning underwrites the
construction of physical set spaces.
But because it is very abstract and not
very specified. We have related in
a much stronger way to the classical
formulation of the FEP where the
internal flow of the agent and the
synchronization manifolds that emerge
from the interaction have a very
specific topology, have a very specific
geometry and can be equipped with
meaning about the underlying physical
structure. Second,
we have to admit that passport realism
is a thing. We have to admit that
there is something wrong in how we view
science. Let us quote
Einstein if without in any way
determining system we can predict with
certainty the value of a physical
quantity, then there exists and the
amount of reality corresponding to that
quantity. By this account, nothing is
real, which is a very big problem,
a very bad position to hold.
And we have in some sense to account
for the role of observation in creating,
well integrating physical states not
only for quantum physics, not only for
cognitive science, but for everything in
between, which is in some sense entailed
by quantum physics, in some sense
entailed by cognitive science. So I
don't think it is a very big deal to say
that, but I think it will be taken as
such. And the statement I
want to make is that not only doing away
with this brand of realism is compatible
with naturalistic Dean with science,
but it's also necessary because for
naturalistic science to be a thing, I
have to represent myself representing as
there is something metaphysical that
comes to play either as taking myself
as a detached, nonphysical describer of
the world or by postulating some kind of
godlike preexisting structure that I
just swapped to stumble upon. You will
have something that is in physics in
some sense if you don't do away with
this brand of evidence. People ism and
it has been said to me that it is not a
new view. No, it is not. It has
been framed as a criticism of the notion
of fat man thinking itself by early
Buddhist philosopher about 3 million
years ago. And the fact it is not
new is not really a problem in my
opinion. We should go with things that
seem true, whether or not they are
exciting and novel and the fact
that we can have a cosmology without
practicing nature and other people
do not find any problem with it should
be a sign that maybe our insistence that
no, there are things in themselves is
not well motivated.
And finally, what I propose
here, beyond physical
considerations and dimension of what
some piece of math do is very
very very basic. Not draft, but drawing
of physical creation that holds
in two movements. The first is
abstractly the inclination of something
from nothing, of order ant cows given
a space of undefined possibilities b
you are the inclination of an observable
that is well defined and of an agent
whose observation of e also individuals
boundary. So we have this kind of
framing that could
work as a handle on how to write
suspense construction. It does have a
very strong category 30 called Filler
from the way basically the content of B
is not what's at stake. This diagram is
pretty much agnostic concerning what B
is and is not. And it must be because it
underwrites the becoming of B and
there is a lot of work if I want the
physics of function to be a thing in
framing properly. What kind of
mathematical operator basically follow
the flow of this diagram and what those
mathematical operators do and the
kind of physics they comma to life. But
for this I have concerning case I have
the case of how humans collaborate to
build and recreate social norms because
it is a case of creation. Like it is
pretty much the single case of creation
I could convince anyone is a thing there
is money because we believe there is
money and it works as we believe it
works because we believe it works this
way. It is very true statement to say
that norms constrain us because
we believe in norms and the
duality it affords between
representation of single agent trying to
understand and act within a social world
and the flow, the interesting flow that
is created by social constraints and
that recreates social constraints it is
pretty specific. It is much more
specific than the vague operator and
on the left and I know this operator
must represent that. So it gives
basically some level of grip ant distant
level on how the physics operation would
work. And they would work by
describing the unfolding of physical
structure as the construction within
physics of meaning and or constraints
over what is observable by viva Nigeria
observers. And pretty
much we have to work from there,
because I do not think there
is no Axel Costa in the sense I
introduced earlier. There is no self
consistent therapistics if we don't do
that, so let's do that.
This work, again, is to some extent
my work is to some extent the collective
work of Keros, which is basically a
battery that works towards an active
sense and active naturalism, a sense
that is naturalist in the sense that it
plays the observer within the world and
works within well defined causal
ontology rather than less well defined
laws and abstract principles.
And it tries to do so in a way that
examples people, as in humans, to
understand their reality to basically
use this knowledge about how the world
works to constrain their own behavior
and navigate the world. Especially given
the recommendation of constraints that
we expect and be explained in the coming
decades. So I strongly suggest you take
a look to our website and our general
line of work and consider if you want to
talk to us or join us. The QR code is,
I believe a link to our website.
So thanks to Maxwell, thanks to Daniel,
thanks to Blei thanks to Yona, thanks to
pretty much everyone who helped me write
this and think it through. It was big
work. So I will run through the
slide if someone wants to read them in
the video. And now we can go toward the
discussion.
Excellent. Thank you.
Thank you, Alexey and Maxwell.
Welcome back. If you want to join and
please, either of you provide
a first statement or any set of
questions, however you want to continue,
just go for it. You know what, give me
five minutes. I will try
to destroy my head.
So chaos, but don't expect me to.
Okay, well, do you want to share
your perspective on the project? Things
that Apple would be familiar with while
you're here? Yeah,
I can begin, I guess.
So I worked on the metaphysical or
ontological ants. And yeah, to me,
Avel gave it a good presentation.
Yeah, it was really nice to see it
framed into the whole way
of talking about everything,
like linking it to SAP and then to
other stuff.
If I can share a bit more about the
metaphysics of the ontology.
The idea was to create an ontology
that is naturalist. And as FEP
seems to be really naturalist, then I
wanted to make it work together. At
first it was only in my own
field that I developed this. Anthony
Chen avel said to me that it was really
linked together. So that's what we
tried to do here.
What does that look like? How are you
evolution what a metaphysic is or how
you know when you found the right one or
an incompatible one. Yeah,
so the basic question was
about the question of what exists more
generally. So that was my anger of
if it's a thing in English.
There are many discussions about what
there is in philosophy, mainly in
the 20th century due to choir. I think
it is popular in general in the culture
of science. So I followed
these debates on what there is and
pretty much there are a lot of views
about what there is and what there is
not. So I was a bit hard to
say that disturbed by the fact that
there are things that are not.
And I wanted to give it a try to talk
about what seems not to be and to make
it exist in some way.
Generally, what doesn't exist is linked
to consistent like Pegasus or
let's say, stupid sentences such as the
round square copy of the college or
something else, such as, I don't know,
some weird, non really mathematical
entities. And I was like, okay, so I
admit that they do not work, but at
least we are talking about them, so
can't we just say they exist in some
way? And then I went into social
ontology and I found that
we can call them social artifacts.
And then I was a bit relieved with this
view. So I tried to make it work
with also phenomenality or cognitive or
personal experience, human experience,
because being a social artifact doesn't
make it all.
Then I just tried to make it work
between ontology, social ontology and
cognitive ontology.
And also something else.
Aval talked about the self referential
inconsistency. So it's a debate I
found. By.
Working on ontology and I was really
into it the fact that the theory is
inconsistent if it doesn't applies to
itself. And I found some
articles about it which were
against naturalism, but one kind of
naturalism only, so it was mostly
naturalism. And I saw that the
people who were working on that, they
didn't know about a lot of naturalism.
And as I worked with Cairo and
in my study, I found that there are many
kinds of meteorologies. So I saw that
the argument doesn't work with other
kinds of materialisms such as the one
that is developed here. I hope it's
clear.
Yes. I'll ask one question on this
topic from the Chat and then feel free
to take it in any direction or Maxwell.
So Adam Rostowski in the chat asked.
Thanks. Avil question. Maybe for Blei.
What if state space is considered
theoretical biology rather than causal
ontology? Its presupposition would then
not be a threat to biological
consistency. So what if state space is
considered theoretical ideology rather
than causal ontology? Maybe just unpack
the question and then give it a thought.
Yeah, I will write it now in order to
reflect on it.
Perhaps Abel just goal directed
question. What are the state spaces that
you're concerned with? How would you
characterize what they are.
By construction state spaces? There are
spaces of postulated physical
possibilities. You have a pretty clear
I do not understand what the notion of
ideology, how it works here,
it's pretty trivial that what we call
ideology will define what a person or
political system or inclination is
capable interested in
seeing.
It is the topic of Scott Singh states
computational, let's say, work of
federal case and biology that looks at
basically how whenever states
try to do things overtly, usually for
the population, their main concern in
effect is to build the capability of
control. And usually they do so by
cutting through complexity aggressively.
Very basic instance of that is
scientific forestry. That is, I can say
it is indeed forestry.
The idea was that Russia needed
Warboats, loads of them. They also
needed to be able to predict how many
Warboats they would build on
a given time frame.
So they need to know how many warbot
compatible trees they had. But you don't
have warboat compatible trees and not
warbot compatible trees. You have trees
from sites, from ages, different
aspects. So if you just counted trees,
even with well defined measure, you
would not really know how many trees you
have. So they just raised forest and
planted homogeneous patch of a given
species ant a given time with a given
soil. So they knew that when they knew
they had 64.
I don't know what trees there are. I
actually know what trees they are. I
don't know it's totally in English. So
it's not oak, but they will say oak to
say something when they knew they had 64
30 years oak. Well, that's 64,
30 years oak.
And that's it. They can cut the trees
and they know exactly what they can do
with it. So this is a way
in which something we could account as
ideology. So the notion that we should
be able to control blah blah, blah blah,
it basically constructs physical
reality in very concrete sense because
they cut free that plant other trees
that fit their expectation. It is a form
of niche construction. It is a form of
how do you call that cognitive
attention, in the sense that the loads
they would need to account for our
Atreides are they just
offloaded onto the environment by making
trees actually the same? And it is a
form of meaning projection. They are the
stamp mining, which is that they need to
count trees that are barboats compatible
and they project it onto like how actual
forests are organized.
Those are physical possibilities as
Dutch by the state. Those are set
spaces. We have a set space that was
very complex with a lot of possible
trees, possible species, possible size.
That is brought down to
how many trees I have. And could
you repeat the question word for word,
please? Because it was not clear to me
how national biology intervened.
What if state space is considered
theoretical ideology rather than causal
ontology its presupposition would then
not be a threat to biological
consistency.
Yes. Okay. Because of ontology precedes
a set space, it is the ontology of
creation constraints that they have
waived. Ant somewhat impressively
at the moment, set space,
I think I will be able to demonstrate
it, but I can't at the moment. They
express the point of view of an agent.
So I imagine that this is what is meant
to be produced by biological
theory, theoretical ideology.
And I do not think Ramstead space
are a threat to ontology. I think
ontologies that consider Ramstead spaces
as fundamental are flow ontology is
fine.
Thank you, AVO Blei, feel free to chime
in and then Maxwell, if you want to add
anything. Yeah, so I
think I will join the commentary.
Also, I would like to say that if
we take clients definition of ideology,
I will not explain this now that well.
Yes. So the idea, I think, is that the
concepts are tool and not fundamental
stuff. That's what I think it is implied
by ideology here.
So what I say is that.
You. Give the value of being an ideology
or consolentology, depending on your
goal and. Your.
But at least minimally, the stuff you're
talking about, that's the fundamental
stuff that I would say.
So even though it is ideological, even
though it is instrumental, let's say
minimally, it is something and it has
consequences on the world. And that's
what I think Avil said with the niche
construction of social time. It didn't
really say that in these words. But even
though your IDs are, let's say, stupid
or absurd and people appear to hear you,
then your IDs, they are in the world and
they do something. So I
hope I answered well. If not,
then I can take questions.
Thank you.
Maxwell, do you want to add something?
Maxwell Ramstead: I don't currently have anything burning
to say. Avel, I think this is
the end iteration of our discussions
around this. As always, I think you did
a great job presenting what I think is a
genuine issue.
And I've just been rehearsing the same
appeals to multi scalarity.
I find it interesting that you would
speak an answer to these issues
in Quantum FEP precisely because
of its scale free nature. So you can't
appeal to a spacetime background when
speaking in the Quantum FEP formulation.
So I think in my mind that makes things
potentially more difficult. I see why
you would want to do that. Because of
the focus on the
definition of an observation as a
physical interaction. I guess my
kind of overarching question
is whether the multi scalarity of
classical FEP helps at all in the
sense that we've described before. So
you have a set of observables, some of
them chance too fast to really disclose
or allow us to track, reliably some
phenomenon behind the blanket, others
do. In the latter case we talk
about states, in the former we talk
about random fluctuations. So I suspect
that the kind of definitional
discussions by which I mean definitions
of states like these kind of
foundational issues that arise in
classical FEP might be helpful
hereabouts. I also suspect that you'll
disagree with me, so I'm looking forward
to hearing your thoughts.
Basically the
distinction is clear between us
at least as your friendly problem. You
seem to be a realist about the physical
possibilities about state spaces which
are not. I have an agreement for non
realism, which is self control
ontological consistency and determinants
of self consistency and self
consistency. That brings us to say that
you can have preemptive set spaces in
which to frame, in which to classify,
have physical observables that somehow
preexist physics, nature,
the process that are within it. So that
is one physical argument. The question
is then can I demonstrate conclusively
that you do not have physical
observables before observation, but
state spaces do in fact reduce the
perspective and observer. And basically,
if I can demonstrate it, the debate is
over. Until then,
you can hold structural values, but you
have to account of how thing exists if
they are not fundamental. I think multi
scale FTP can do that. So it's not a
critical problem for you. Everything
holds on the formal demonstration that
we do not in fact have sex basis
as prompted physical affect.
Well, I would push a little bit back
against your realism versus antirealism
distinction here.
I'm really just talking about like at
the level of the formalism. You start
with some observables, which seems to be
what you are also saying,
and then you can talk about the way that
those observables are related to some
other things which may be latent. All of
that is a formal statement as far as I'm
concerned. And it is useful
whether or not it maps in some kind of
fundamental realist ontology sense. I
guess if there is a kind of
transcendental overtone to what I'm
saying in the sense that we've argued
in print, on the map territory, fallacy
fallacy paper, that the FEP theoretic
maths and the related cluster of
principles, unitarian, maximum entropy
and so forth provide ultimate
constraints on any model building
exercise, just full stop. So again,
that doesn't presuppose any realism
about what maps map onto. It's really
just a statement about the construction
and maybe the process of constructing.
You're correct. It says I was
attributing, I don't know to say
English, it was not accurate to frame
you as a realist about its basis. It was
correct, however, to frame you as an
instrumentalist, which I refuse to be
because of naturalism, basically I
consider it necessary to frame causal
ontologies that map, onto reality
properly, as fine grandly as we can.
And to do that we have to include
basically the translation relation. And
this is when everything becomes
complicated because you can't say if
there are such physical possibilities,
then this occurs. You can't use that
language because by doing that you
frame physical possibilities as
something that is abstracted from the
underlying physical reality. You
decouple the formal from the actual.
And I think whatever ontology we use
must be what reality is, must correspond
structurally to what drives reality.
So it is the contrary. It is who
is the realist. But the constraint I was
going to. Suggest maybe
actually.
I go for ontology that is consistent in
the sense I friend and the constraint of
that are much stronger than the
constraint of our instrumentalist
anthology that just we say interesting
things, which is not actually easy,
it's just much more easy. But suppose we
started from the assumption that we
don't have to have a strong position on
the reality of state spaces.
Does that affect your agreement at all?
If I were to say I just as a
practitioner of science start from my
observables, you can be a radical
phenomenologist from this point of view
if you want. You're just starting from
your observables and then working out
like what resists your manipulations or
interactions. Does that,
in your view, kind of allow us to move
around asking the questions about.
You can move around with oh, about the
fix upgradion? No. Move around. Yes.
Understand some things with cognitive
meaning. Yes. You have FEP grounds
cognitive meaning in Demiko sampiri.
It's huge. Did what
it does not is afford the ontological
consistent theory of physics and the
difference between us is not what we
hold the FEP to do. I think we're both
instrumentalists from
you as a realist but the
difference is that I see an affordance
to build a much stronger self consistent
physical theory that draws element and a
general philosophy from the FEP, the
philosophy of activity in France.
Basically I
push in this direction because I think
the goal is variable. It is ultimately
an ethical call. If you do not agree
that the goal is variable you should not
agree that it is useful to push it. I do
not have ultimately any show of that.
Maybe there is a kind of Conor intake
here because I think at least in the
history of philosophy this split between
realism and antirealism or
instrumentalism I think it's perhaps
overly simplistic as a description of
the potential options.
There is a whole contein line of
thinking that talks about something
intermediate in some sense.
I don't know, just a thought.
Is a dam in the room? If you're in the
room, use the chat.
But in a sense I agree that.
Not in the room. But I can read another
question whenever you're done. I'll read
another question from the Chat. Yes,
but I was going to say something which
is that I agree that basically is a
distinction between instrumentalism and
annualism must be dissolved because none
of them are ecological consistent. Both
suppose representation relation that is
outside the world and the question is
whether the words as a formal construct
correspond to the reality as a
structural thing. It's not a constant
question to ask the all of the things
are in the world. We have to have a
theory of our things are true or not.
That affords for the statements we have
about the world to be in the world
because they are.
And so from the moment once
you free that biological consistency is
something to have a lot of the
distinction we have in western
philosophy will be dissolved. Which
makes communication complicated. Of
course.
Maxwell, you want a closing thought on
that or I'll ask the next question?
You can ask the next question. I think
that brings us nicely to.
This is from Alex Kiefer. So Alex wrote
I love the positive story in this paper
insofar as I understand it, which I'm
still working on and the idea of
treating even such things as state
spaces and scientific reps as amenable
to physical descriptions. But to bounce
off what Maxwell is saying I am not sure
I see the deep critique of thing in
itself realism here probably depends
what one means by that. I tend to think
of the strictly incoherent concept idea
of something unknowable behind
phenomena. So why is treating statespace
correlation as part of phenomena at odds
with that? And it's also Ramstead in the
chat. Just to pick up on that, I think
you don't need to be a strong realist.
You can just believe that you are more
or less getting it right. And the
semantics that we've proposed that uses
active coherence and the free free
energy principle, the kind of formal
basis precisely uses the fact that you
have a certain perspective, you have
certain beliefs, and your beliefs are
going to be more or less wrong and that
the prediction error or the free energy
is precisely the
kind of minimal ingredient that you need
to hook you into a situation enough to
be doing something pragmatic that you
might call truth telling.
That's really all you need from a formal
point of view is just the ability to be
wrong and to change your mind in light
of new evidence. So my claim is not that
everything in physics is false and
formal statements about postulated
possibilities of no epistemic value or
trivial epistemic value. My claim is
that those representation,
as any representation are rational.
They relate to objects and the
true value or value in a sense that we
have to give the meaning we have to give
to that if we are to give anything at
all must be grounded in the study of
physical dynamics that's underlying our
emergence. If we are to have
again an ontologic consistent theory.
We could just say that evidence is
discourse that is not entirely false and
say things that are not entirely false.
We could do that.
Again, the notion that physical
discourse must be legally consistent is
ultimately ethical like it is a
statement on what you should and should
not do. I can say that it is better
because XYZ you can say that XYZ are not
meaningful targets to have and that
whatever we do is okay essentially, or
maybe it's better than X-Y-Z.
But the notion that I do
not critique the spaces but at least
it's Ronen point, I have to frame it as
a critique for it to resonate.
But the point is that the spaces are
rational property and that to study
this rationality, it reframes the
entirety of physics, it's epistemology
it's ontology, it's cosmology. And if
you look ant the flow of this theory,
it's not least action, it analyzes
social evolution. Revolution is agent
producing meaning as norms and then the
norms when they think it is something
that is very basic for
us to understand how solar system
evolves. And yet there is no
such theory, there is no theory of such
revolution that do not presupposes
variation and obstruct away any form of
structure and metabolism. It simply
does not exist. So the nonexistence
of a materialistic theory of revolution
is maybe a pretty big problem for a
purely predictive pragmatic value
standpoint. From a more abstract
standpoint, we don't have a Korean
cosmology, we don't have an explanation
for why there are things and why the
things that are look like what they are
physically. We just have to postulate
that space time is such and such
for physics to make sense. Which is a
problem. We can't have a
physical theory that stands only on the
fact that its statement does not give
rise to obvious problems. We have to
have something beyond the statement. We
have to have some way to account for how
this statement became true. And it is a
pretty basic point to make in
psychology, biology, sociology. We can't
just say things are such and such. We
have to say how they become such and
such and why they become such and such.
It is nothing in evolution, nothing
biology makes like nothing
in biology makes sense except in light
evolution. And it is because those
are systems that are I don't like Telegy
call, let's say teleonomical. Those are
things that are organized, that are
coherent, that work in a specific way.
And so we have to
cannot just say they do x, we have to
say how and why they do x. And this
epistemology has
not permeated physics basically because
of the belief of physicist in Platonic
truth of symmetries or formalism or
symmetry. I have a question force you.
So I'm thinking about this in terms of
the direction of travel, of our research
on the free energy principle which I
mean, there are two main components too
that we could discuss that are relevant
here. The first is the move from state
based to path based or path integral
formulations where what's
at stake is precisely probability
density function is not over individual
but over trajectories, entire
trajectories of a system where what your
generative model Lagrangian is
describing is the probability of some
specific history. So this kind
of intrinsically historical
formalization and on the other hand,
as a kind of second main direction of
travel really formalizing these kind of
three nested scales of inference where
you have inference over state factors
and individual states like color and
red, green, Bleu and so on coherence
over the parameters of the model.
The characterized the relations between
states and configurations of states and
finally the structure of the model which
is really like the actual relations
and functionality of what is connected
to what. So one of the things that we're
working on is getting to the
mathematical foundations of these
basically mutually constraining scales
of inference. So suppose you had access
to a path based description of the free
energy formalism supplemented
by a clear formulation of
inference nested within parameter
optimization, nested within structure
optimization. In other
words, assuming that we solve structure
learning, which is a big assuming,
but if you granted those two things,
would there be still much of a problem?
You think, from a formal point of view,
if you could just move in the space of
all possible model structures and paths
through such spaces,
would you not basically address what you
have in mind here?
Three things. First, bath integral.
It solves the issue of preset meaning
for vertical assistance and the issue of
that already. But it is not something I
called on here so it would not help with
the issue I've discussed. Secondly is
structured learning. The question is how
basically living things project
structure. If we have that we would
progress in a big way for a theory
of cognitive meaning and agency.
But you will still operate within
a given space of possibilities. You will
have attraction conversation of
the state of possibles by
virtue of what the FEP is it builds
manifold. So the manifold the thing will
evolve on the manifold where it will
evolve. So some of active states space
would become trivial, some of the
dimension will become trivial and
some things that do not really appear
per se in the set space will become
relevant. So they will become part of
this data space as experienced by the
agent. But the hard part is to account
for how this test space as
experienced by the agent becomes this
test space per C. How you have matrix
of six or six that serves
as a boundary, let us say. And how
agents will basically collaboratively
build tissemoso meaning where they have
alphabet and can communicate long
sentences using this grid.
And this is not in and of itself
a question of structure learning.
Although solving structure learning
wasn't able to
have a lot of computational experiments
that would help greatly with looking at
the fine brain structure. The question
is how
you use mathematics in a way well,
in a way that describes creation. That
the concept of the spaces. That's what
I'm suggesting within the space. That's
what I'm suggesting when so the what I'm
talking about is if you could figure out
when to add a new node
or edge to your generative
model like precisely when is it
appropriate to add a new parameter?
When is it appropriate to say oh, these
two parameters are connected to that
state in these proportions. If you have
that worked out I could see a kind of
straightforward resolution to what we're
just talking about. The system just
unfolds dynamically and occasionally it
learns new structure or parameters which
basically means like new degrees of
freedom are added to the system.
You are again talking at the epistemic
level. You can describe a lot of things
by basically looking at the dynamics and
being smart about it. You don't even
need advanced mathematics to do that.
The statement we make is different. Let
us say that you have people that agree
that shells are an appropriate means of
exchange for x, y and z.
Then money becomes a thing. It is a
thing that exists individually because
it has structural properties and these
properties drive observables through
dynamics and equally inevitably
did not exist Ronen before. The question
we ask is how we account for an
evolution within a space that builds
another space and we cannot
just look at the space and declare how
it has changed. It is not the problem
we are posing. Problem is how it's
present mathematically something that
occurs within space, that proves another
space that is the same but not the same,
that is structurally similar,
that inherits from what existed before,
but is different in quality of aspects
because this one thing became. So what
we have to have is a theory of becoming,
basically. And we can be
very smart about modeling things without
having a theory of becoming. We can be
very precise nimco interference and very
efficient at seeing regime
changes. That does not mean we have a
self consistent theory of becoming.
Creation, test based construction,
connectivity like those are two
different problems, although 1 may help
the other. regretly, both may help the
other greatly because the thing we are
looking at is the same way, looking at
two very different aspect of the thing.
Maxwell, want to add something or Alexa
on that? No, I'm going to think about
that. Thank you. Avel awesome.
Yeah. From the chat on that topic, Tom
wrote a similar question. Avel, could
you elaborate more on how active could
be expanded to accommodate state space
creation? Assuming active is normative
about free energy minimization, when
should an agent expand the state space?
And Alex Kiefer also kind of added a
note it's appropriate to add a new
parameter when the model complexity
accuracy trade off says so. More
seriously, isn't free energy measurable
across models or different state spaces?
So it's almost like there's the
structure learning metacognition
layer and it almost is like can the
box be wrapped within the box? Can it be
possible to have a state space that
within its state space represents
itself? And or to what extent do
these physical intermediates and their
associated physics and metaphysics need
to come into play for different systems
and at what level of generality?
Basically, about this, I subscribe to a
variant of consistent history
interpretation of quantum physics. But
it's not quantum physics. It's just
something that has the kind of optical
properties quantum physics has.
Well, I did commit to quantum
indoctrination theory earlier, so okay,
let us say it is in nature quantum,
which is a bit trivial because, yes, it
has pieces in it, which is what being
quantum is. But whatever.
This is the most specific mathematically
consistent white presented that I found.
Do you still see those slides? Yes,
EBA. EBA Bay.
And this is basically category theory
because this diagram
as a property, which is that following
the arrows basically change what spaces
b begins as ancestral interface. So a
space of possibilities that in principle
a fault interaction, but it is not
semantically loaded. And the fact that
you have the Nigeria of E, the
Observables and A, I framed it as an
agent, but it would rather be adaptive
capabilities or constraints that enabled
observation of E.
So this
does not conserve the property of B
because B becomes equipped with
semantics. So we have theories
that look at spaces without looking
at what is in spaces. Those are category
theories. And those are the most
abstract field of mathematics as far as
I know. And they do not afford
semantically loaded things like free
energy. Energy is a measure of not only
it entails of states, but it also
entails measure of states. I think the
basic mathematical structure we need to
work on that is much more
basic than any other things. And any
energy measure will break down much
before we get there. But what
we have that is more semantically loaded
is this the duality between the
experience of struggle to landscape by
agents and the entrance flow
that is created by the landscape and
reconsider the landscape. So the
question was what was the question?
Could you repeat it? Word force word
Daniel. It was
just about the normativity
around model selection and whether
modeling states spaces could or
would require the
artifact. The activity
is there it is in
this representation of the problem, I
have a small agents that represent
circuit landscape and act within it.
And I can just claim, okay, there is a
set space, there is a flung destined
space. I can defend energy. These agents
minimize strategy. And then this
is where structural learning intervenes,
basically, because those agents will try
to understand the world. They do not
experience the world directly. They will
infer the world in a way that is robust
and competent, but they can make
up new things they can fail to
understand. They can cheat, they can
erode the structure of the landscape
that is collectively enacted in many
ways. And this, again is
duel to something that is dynamics.
Actually, I do not know what it is. It
doesn't have a word. The unfolding of
the structure of the landscape under its
own flow. That, again, is not
dynamics because it's not what the
sensory says. We described what
you're talking about in terms of niche
construction in human systems.
Karl and I had an interesting discussion
about this a few weeks ago. And yeah, I
think what really distinguishes human
systems from non human systems is the
degree to which active inference lab
loop is mediated by what would otherwise
be internal states, but end up having
this kind of ambiguous function. Of
yeah, they're environmental, but they
encoding the material aspects of some
normative practice or some store some
information about what you're doing,
like a blackboard, for instance, or
these slides that we're all looking at
in some sense, encode the thought or
aspects of the thought that you're
trying to communicate.
Maybe a lot of the problem here can be
finessed by noting that it's not just
about agents interacting with each
other. There is a kind of common store
of traces,
like a kind of material thing that we
all have in common. Yes.
You have a common collective action of
given structural landscape because
humans are such that then they
synchronize in a robust and smooth sky
loaded way. And that structural
landscape, it does not exist.
It is not something that pre exists.
The fact that agents do that agents
infer properties and then enact them.
And this makes it an open landscape.
And the normativity of the FEP affords
probably a computational experiment
design that help us see how such
landscape unfolds and look at material
theory where the agent is absent, where
it is landscape that produce the
landscape. And once we have that, we
have a theory of creation. It is what
the theory of creation is. So what
you're saying is if we had a theory
where the agent was able to expand its
state space through structure and
parameter learning in particular, then
we would have what you're looking for.
Am I misunderstanding?
Yes. But I'm not sure that we agree that
we're relying on the constraints that
this segment entails.
Not sure I see what you do. Because the
goal is not to understand how the agent
engage with personnel environment, it is
to obstruct. If we get to
the target, we can obstruct entirely the
agent in what they think and just look
at constraints and how they informed. I
went light on Axel Costa because we do
not have it was not the place for that.
But we need to look at specifically
constraint over what is observable and
how they are invigorated and how they
produce other constraints, etc, etc. We
have to get back at this.
Constraints are dual to priors.
I mean, you're talking about the same
thing. But the formulation that
is taken in physics often by belief is
DST. It entails primitive space.
And this is what needs to be to address
the problem I want to address. This is
why to have to be overcome
and this is likely
possible given constraints and trick
ontology. So biology where do not have
possibilities, then constraints of other
possibilities, but constraints, then
possibilities afforded by constraints.
And I do know what I'm saying. Is that
those two stories are the same story.
That's what Bayesian Mechanics says.
Within DST. But they're both from
DST. So a
free energy principle theoretic model of
the belief updating of a particle in a
system is in the strong sense of like
is dual to you. If I have one, I have
the other. Right? Is a maximum entropy
dynamical systems model of the whole
system, as in the whole system of
particles and environment to which it's
coupled and all of that sensory Conor.
That's the cool thing. The FEP is
the canonical optimal dynamical systems
model. It's maximum entropy in the sense
that it
makes the least assumptions given your
current state of knowledge about the
system. It's James.
As in J-A-Y-N-E-S.
It's James. Optimal in the Parliament.
So belton shock mebodyville. Yes.
If you have a constraints model, you
also have an FEP model and vice versa.
If you work it out from the perspective
of the FEP, you can map back onto
constraints. But definitionally,
if you can frame a. Constraint model
with no reference whatsoever to the
ecosystem theory or preexisting spaces.
Yes, I agree, you have solved the
problem but the paper
which we refer to frames it within DST
so it has those
that we need to get beyond to solve this
specific problem. Again, I do not mean
to say basically you have framed this
equivalence, I think up
to details, let us say up to details I
would need to think about it actually,
but with the potentials that are
precisely those that I want to use the
equivalents to the Conor. So it is not I
guess I'm. Just saying that constraints
don't get you out of the problem that
you were posing originally either like
both you have another kind
of layer of pregiving static.
Is not we have to characterize
constraints, it is that we have to have
an ontology of constraints. So
mathematical controls that Axel Costa
with no reference to anything else,
just constraints. What means? I don't
know. But if we have that in the sense
while considering the sense that is
given by Monsieur Moreno and while
leveraging the equivalence between
constraints and belief that meaning
belief, whatever that is derived we have
one, but it is not something that has
been done because FEP is friend within
vanillafep, vfep is friend
within DST, which basically states and
Qfeps does
not specify what build observable is,
just specify that there are observables
that we can make obeyed.
But we can't solve this within DST or
within pure abstract quantum
indoctrination. So it is not afforded by
the structure of this series one
prospective states, the other
prospective observers we have to show
how those are becoming
integrated and the only
way forward that I see is a constraint
biology. Right, but what I'm saying is
mathematically speaking, if you're
talking about constraints then there is
a in the end it's probably function.
I mean, you know, there is a rigorous
and systematic mapping from what you're
talking about to what the FEP is already
saying.
That's really what the duality is saying
maximizing your entropy with respect to
some set of constraints is cue to
minimizing your free energy with respect
to some model. It's the same thing if
you have one, you always have the other.
How would you frame the notion of a
constraint in the sense of control
Monteville and Moreno with no reference
to either DST or in the United States?
Well, I mean in these reaction networks
that they're mapping, they are
implicitly using. Some kind of reaction
networks. It is another line of work.
Right, but I'm just saying that there is
a similar kind of individuation of
things that's going on when you map out
some kind of constraint schematic.
In that sense, the point that you're
making sort of like grandfathers both
here, which is okay, but how do you
write down a state space model at all?
And how do you grow them in particular?
But I guess I'm just saying, yeah,
constraints are just as subject to this
as to the extent that the FEP is subject
to your criticism. The constraint stuff
is also for the same or dual reasons.
If you just inverted all of the arrows
in your reasoning, you would also be
able to apply this to the constraint
stuff equally. That's not an exit to
what you're pointing out. But I guess my
complimentary point is if you
think moving to Axel constant ontology
helps us, then that's interesting
because any constraint mapping is also
cue to an FEP theoretic model. So maybe
the FEP can be used like very directly,
just based on the way that you're like
if you solve the problem in terms of
constraints, you could flip it back.
I don't know. If you're stuck along the
way, then you can flip it at that point
and think, okay, well, looking at
it from this, do I want to look at self
organization from the perspective of the
cells that are self organizing or from
the perspective of organization and the
maximization of entropy and all that
stuff? I guess so if you're doing that,
the FTP treats a naturally different
problem. This is not a view. This is a
view opposed. Specifically. I do agree
that physics of and by belief derives
within the st rigorous relation between
basically what are the two sides of this
up to details. What I am saying
is framing as a goal the fact to
leverage that as a way to build
a mathematical theory of state space
construction. And I also claim that this
would be essentially equivalent to build
self consistent constraint
biology for that,
for this diagram. I'm not sure what you
are going against, because it is an
ambiguous that your research as of now
is framed within DST, which presupposes
states, which the constraint biology
would not. And it is ambiguous that is
very relevant because it, as you said,
entails one duality, at least in one
specific case, which is this of DST.
That is the key problem to address.
So I think you may be combining two
issues in this worry.
There's the worry of like new states
arising and there's the worry of using
states at all.
Okay,
the problem is not really that dynamical
systems theory assumes states,
it's just the static nest of
the predeterminedness
or the prespecified nest.
Okay, if that's specifically your
worries, there is a very fruitful way
forward, I think, to address a lot of
them. My proposal
is a state space construction, not
states based negotiationism. To get A,
I need B to begin with, I need physical
things to be there. Well, to have
actually selfconstitute, you would need
this to work from ex nilo to get
something from nothing. But it is not
the issue at hand here. The issue at
hand here is how existing things can
unfold create whatever meaning states.
So it is not the notion of states that
is the problem. The problem is the fact
that we do not have a theory of how
states are created and we cannot frame
it exclusively from mathematical
theory that by construction presupposes
a space of possibilities. We can,
however, from this theory to
generalize it to the space construction,
which is what I'm proposing. But what
about the renormalization group? So if
you start really from the idea that you
just have observations and they
have a scale of noise associated
with them,
there are principled physics kind of
ways of bootstrapping. Something kind of
saying, well, some stuff changes.
So fast relative to my reference scale
that it basically averages out and just
contributes kind of random fluctuations
to what. I'm observing,
whereas possibilities and you
look at basically a way to analyze it,
to look brain evolution scales. But
maybe it would be afforded to other
pastoralism, but it does not intend, it
does not model past realism. It is a
model of how complex things, complex,
dynamic, unfold.
So it is relevant. It is not what I'm
pointing at.
Right. As we
come near the end. For each of us,
maybe you can spend the most time avil,
but for each of us, what are our next
steps? What cognitive counterfactuals
and physical embodiments are going to be
shaped by this work and discussion?
Maybe we can have nonaval go first and
then you can have the last word. Sound
good? Okay.
Well, personally, I'm very excited to
work on the category theory this year,
learning about the recent dissertation
of Toby Smith.
Also, I think it's interesting to bring
in that niche modification active
infrast variational ecology. A lot
of the work that, as Maxwell brought up
earlier, had been framed within a
multiscale setting, bringing some of
these new developments over the last one
or two years, like the path based
formalization renormalization group,
environmental process, generative,
process, generative, model, Symmetries,
Weak, Markov, Blanket. There's just many
new concepts and toolkits on the table
today in 2023 than I think there were
one or two or three years ago. So it's
been a super interesting discussion and
it brings a lot of topics to our
attention that I expect will be
able to reduce our uncertainty about a
lot in the coming year. I'll pass to
Blei, then Maxwell, and. Then Apple,
the opposite. It would be more
consistent because Blei and I goal
directed together in controls. Okay,
maxwell?
Well, I mean, Daniel, I would echo your
overall assessment. I share your
enthusiasm for where everything is
at right now. I think we're poised for
some very exciting work and a lot of
very interesting stuff has happened over
the short term in terms of what Aval
presented. I think in
addition to what you were describing,
one of the things I want to work out
this year is really the loss of the free
free energy principle Bayesian
mechanics. I think up until recently,
what most everyone has been doing,
myself included, was just coming at this
thing from whatever disciplinary
background we had access to and trying
to just make sense of it. But I think
that has made us kind of blind to some
of the and everyone has kind of their
blind spots. All of these so called
interpretations of the FEP signal to
me that there's philosophical work
to be done to kind of understand. Jules
had just put it nicely on Twitter. I
think he said that he'd become convinced
of two things. First, the FEP is true in
the sense that it's quote unquote, the
right way to do it. And second, that
it's a lot more like boring than all the
hype suggest in the sense that it just
follows from the way that a bunch of
physics hooks up. It's very fundamental
and important. But yeah,
it's part of the kind of core package
now and there are new exciting horizons
of unknown. But more
to the point is there's like a
kind of core philosophy to the Sat that
d Maisto be developed? So for example,
the duality between the principle of
maximum entropy which implements
a form of like Akama's razor in some
sense and the free energy principle I
think is kind of deep. But we've only
started to think about the implication
that have and Chris Fields group has
been suggesting that there's a similar
duality between the FEP and unitarity
or the conservation of classical
information in quantum information
theory. So that's
very exciting. Sorry for talking so
long. Awesome exciting times
indeed. All right, Alexey, and avoid
with the final words.
Yes, I will be short.
So I'm really excited about how these
debates will move the lines in
theoretical but also practical
philosophy and on goal directed
perception of stuff in life in general
to be a bit broad. Also, I hope
that all of this
will make the difference in metaphysics
and ontology in philosophy and meta
biology and naturalism, of course,
as it seems to do in active insurance
lab and chaos.
We need to do to set all the dust on the
agreement I generated there. The first
is to formalize much better segmental.
Biological consistency and
phosphorialism both need to be very
clear in their reach and
entailments. This is something we'll do
with Alexey Menlee and possibly
autograph members.
Something that we need to do too is to
put a lot of work in working out what
these Bay things mean. I do not know.
I can tell you that it is essentially
correct. I'm pretty confident that
essentially correct, but I have no idea
whatsoever what it means, but which is
pretty big problem as far as I'm
concerned. So there will be a lot of
work for me and other members,
namely Yanabrinak and Maxine Chimole to
work out the specifics of this
mathematical thing that
allows order to unfold from chaos.
And most pressingly in my opinion
at least, it's what I'm supposed to
focus on in terms of flow. It is to
work out what this means, how social
constraints are enacted and how they
evolve, because ultimately the rest is
abstraction. This is what has content.
This is what allows us to say, okay,
these are what exists. These are the
constraints that shape things, and this
is what is their flow.
It is critical from centric
perspective because it is what gives me
to listen to our accounts. It is
critical from pragmatic perspective
because it is what tells us what
world we are in and what is its flow,
which is the goal of Cairos, something
we'll do with mainly my own job
and Venus Gonzalez. And so,
basically, we will work around the
specific of this. And if someone starts
to collaborate, please write us. We will
be very interested because there is a
lot of all of these problems are big
problems, all hidden states, a lot of
firepower. So, basically, anyone who
wants to, who's interested in working
all the specifics with us is very much
invited to reach out.
Excellent. Thank you, Alexey Apple and
Maxwell, for joining. Thanks,
everybody, for watching. Till 34.2.
All right, it's over. Thanks.
Yeah, thanks, both fellows.